let's start this bad boy I am so ready I
didn't get any items do we still have
the millions go I didn't look we
probably still have a five billion they
don't want to even use it I'm not a
cheater I would never cheat ever dick
likley is gonna have the revolver okay
that always just makes me laugh oh so
good literally a prosperous so let's see
okay I've got I've got my you wanna
trade rolls at all no no I I like doing
calls out so when I do call out what
like how long your periscope is hang on
check this out watch watch this yeah I'm
watching wow man
dick likley has the longest periscope
I've ever seen I'm gonna I'm in it okay
so what I'm gonna do is my call-out
system is enemies are gonna be a number
and that's a number on the clock right
locations is gonna be left right middle
and that's your generally the path that
you should go so in enemy pops up I'll
be like 5 o'clock path middle path left
path right or go right or left left
right middle and I'll always call where
the open path to go is and you'll you'll
you'll totally be able to rely on me
I'll be there by your side do we want
one gun or two gun ones probably
adequate for the beginning we might need
to up that okay middle path middle path
middle drifting left an enemy what is
that that's a purple fish okay we're
good there's an update so there's gonna
be new [ __ ] we haven't seen really okay
far left far right go left right is a
boss fight okay yeah there's gonna be
there's gonna be some new stuff probably
we may have to fight a new boss if we
get far enough oh hell yeah
you know I love
no is this a hermit cavers I said no all
right stay behind me boys all right you
got it dick likley wait why would the
guy with the lick them harder why would
the guy with a gun not be behind that's
on my face
help shoot me chewy the face I'm
shooting you I'm cute okay don't worry
bud I'm here I'm here to help
mark could probably use a couple whacks
yeah man if you could whack me let me
walk you yeah please whack me thank you
you're not you're not waking me consider
yourself whacked
thanks I do all right mmm wait there
might be a he rolls down here boy F outs
friends this crap drop it down
let's Carol to something Harold thought
so
Carol get out now can you touch me daddy
Wade yeah we got a backpack up here
maybe Wade what we got two backpacks you
guys can have them it's I'm useful being
a gun a gun daddy
okay us exclusively begun daddy that's
fun yeah I could be shoot the guns on
the boat I shoot the guns at oh that way
are we uh
is there more this is I'm just gonna
pretend like I wasn't letting it thanks
for the wax daddy give me a window
window guys my screens still broken so
you guys are just broken maybe what we
died you should like reinstalled I know
why I know why wait I know why cuz
you're a weirdo when you plan a 4k
monitor oh you have a 4k monitor yeah is
that a problem with that yeah yeah
why do you plan a 4k monitor that's just
very 1440 is where it's at my man I I
think 4k is nice all right pass straight
down and hit go
the moment he pada the first possible
moment that far right do three o'clock
four o'clock
and up top sharp old 2 o'clock shark to
aquinas shark 1 o'clock grabby grabby
[ __ ]
grabby [ __ ] is 130 times now another
folks in grabby [ __ ] oh [ __ ] he's dead
many sharks make sure we're still full
health patching the hole
alright I'll kind of slow down cuz I
need you to guide me alright yeah we
straight down do right enemy six o'clock
alright just around the corner
Oh swordfish we probably gonna hit us
mmm miss we miss with bubble 730 oh yeah
three swordfish - swordfish now both
above okay two paths left and right I
can't see what they go - what is that
that's a boss to the right don't go
right [ __ ] okay well we're too late flat
faced an enemy yep
no oh the squids following us go inside
Oh God look out apparently wait why'd
you go to the boss fight I went to the
cave that's a boy I'm chambers the boss
fight I will revive you no God I went in
the boat wait have grabbed I got grabbed
revive them it's fine
wait makes them make some room get away
I could shoot him from pretty far away
he does until you die oh that sucks
see if you could dodge roll past him and
and actually no just stay with me we'll
get mark after Oh
Mark's wrench couldn't really help too
much anyway
good help I can do good with it hey
that'd have to be close enough for him
to be able to grab you which is not good
it's hey I can dodge the grabs I can do
it I can dodge that good stand still
heater and kill him with my guns I will
[ __ ] you up if you question my skill
again no you have to go past him he
might grab you
no just don't get grabbed it's disease
you try it go try and save mark dodge
roll space your space your way Oh Iggy
stays a guard on you careful wood you
got it he's got he's so good he's so
good he's a grown on me we got a whack
me whack me whack me alright wait no I'm
good I'm
all right here we go yeah you you
respawn at full health while you lose a
health but out for you wagon and mark
real good I'm just I'm distracting his
grabby hand he won't grab you I
guarantee that place over here where we
can stand no no [ __ ] shroud up in
there oh come get me come get me
thank you thank you keep going and there
I'm good okay
Oh punch not today not today
Oh miss me with that yeah oh I'm
whacking them alright I'm so I've got
this guy on my reaction times are
unbelievable oh me oh me that was all me
that's a gun upgrade I think no no it's
not Wade we get it your screen is there
anything up here oh I fell there's
something what's that
that looks cool that's cool I got a
backpack spot you want oh no wait you
you get it so you can alternate if you
you get that suit of this it looks
impressive I've got it I think what it
do it's a magic wand oh [ __ ] come down
here because I can't make the jump
across because I'm an idiot what is it
Oh what does it do it either heels or
boots wherever I seem to heal me if
exists it makes a little dupes I think
it's a gun I think it that probably
damages enemys weights are made yeah
alright in the back and then in your
white speech nice man me get off the
bald fly sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
sorry
I thought of it now you dig fast enough
to think I should say it sorry sorry
consider yourself not healed come on
it's fine it's okay it's okay right
where's all friends here okay it's all
just for Fitz jokes right it's just haha
listen listen yeah I can't off the ball
I don't do that as much as most of the
other friends that we hang out with what
does that do
oh that looks awesome oh [ __ ] oh hey
sharks [ __ ] you oh oh enemy nine o'clock
far off I actually see your harpoons
when they're shooting that's fun on my
radar that's funny okay nine o'clock
nine o'clock
oh we're damaged oh sorry I'm drowning I
didn't realize we were damaged I'm
really committed to these call-out guys
it was a cave here yeah that's a town oh
yeah civilization let's go kill him all
right yeah we got some money and now
that we know that we can pull our money
that's really helpful that's how the
white mage we pull out my staff don't
pull out your spare I just really not to
shoot anyone who a laser zap oh uh
that's a machine gun but I don't think
we need combine our money somehow yeah
we all just stand near it and hold EE
until the purchase is done I won this
mass
I could but I would we don't have enough
for that yeah I could get this gun and
then I could have a gun and a wrench I
guess you want it I'll do it yeah what
do i press against you hold E until it
fills up no I've got enough money you
don't have to buy it for me yeah you
could buy it by himself I mean do you I
mean don't stop if that's what you
really want I already poured all my
money oh yeah that's right yeah oh no it
just stays in there oh that's not
because you were shared my thank you man
thank you wait till I get on the ship to
shoot this the white mage is very
straight in the air do you think it'd
not be be like celebratory they would be
like all right oh it's like a it's like
an ice laser or electricity I'm in the
ship well now my regular old gun seems
pretty stupid well no we got you got
physical
I've got electrical he's got green green
oh my god okay stead why you panic Sulu
I thought a huge tentacle little baby
that was that was a little bit
underwhelming for the react I'm a white
mage that was horrifying for healer of
the final right right okay of course you
you wait you right all right let's go
let me see how fast this harpoon fires
with two guns I just want to see oh my
god yeah we're going into the boss fight
enemies do you want the harpoon double
gun or anything maybe double gun okay
but three various switch to mm probably
that like Orca right that's not the
first one isn't it isn't the first one
just a big we know we know the strategy
yeah yeah he's got a spot right above it
right yeah and don't shoot any of this
[ __ ] yeah I know shoot oh no it's fine
it's not hard but it's very tense so I
don't shoot anything but the boss right
yeah do I just do you guys just fight
off the switch off if you can guarantee
a shot do it but yeah just aim for the
mouth with it anywhere other than
straight down engines off mark
oh yeah engines off that's right do that
you could turn chain saw something
shields up okay we have gotten even or
whatever I don't know are we in the
right spot it's almost dead it's almost
dead oh holy [ __ ] all right
oh my god let's go then I guess it's
dead okay the double harpoons is pretty
that's pretty powerful that was just for
fun I'm gonna start shooting this little
[Laughter]
man hey what's up oh you guys are making
out on my screen all right super lights
okay lights on oh boy but we should be
okay
so long as it is real slow and
methodical we got the fire bar right
okay engine's going on
we got the Poon's you got the Pune's we
got strong punish bubble on away from us
five enemy damage I think the best part
is the pushback yeah okay okay Chucky's
left and right I can't see go a little
lower
hermit crab right and I still can't see
what's left but hermit crab maybe
yeah hermit crabs cool alright yeah
there's also an enemy or a ball directly
south balls are nice
six o'clock ball oh the other one was a
boss fight anyway so this is fine I
apparently one shot that enemy so that's
cool
nice yeah I can't remember if the balls
are good or bad to hit are they bad I
think they're not so good to hit but I
don't remember the bubbles for the ball
the ball like hard balls on an enemy or
something it's trash nobody I can spare
dance damn that would be great if we
could double up on that if we had a ship
with two guns we could so we can't even
pick up that right yeah we can't not
everything too bad of all the things
damn it oh well it's fine
Lisa really wants us to get the harpoon
alright we're going we go is that new or
have we just not seen that before no
yeah that's good question we're driving
Oh
I assume that you're ready when we get
in here where else would he go I want to
play with my mustache does have the
furthest to go so by the time he gets to
his station we should be like you know
mentally ready path path right side
straight down so nice and just peaceful
and creepy and dark right here it's
weirdly open sucking Wallace Wallace
lucky [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna try to stay
at wall master didn't shoot those things
I'm not sure right straight down
it's just weirdly open and empty like my
soul wow there's a pavri far left and
right but I think they go to the same
place nothing on radar this is
uncomfortable yeah it really is there's
gonna be like twelve enemies at some
point you want me to clear this I don't
know what you're shooting it oh yeah
does seaweed stuff yeah just so we don't
get stuck feel free be good call keep
going just keep going down this is so
empty and weird we got it's fine no Dee
balls
seven o'clock and
eight o'clock far-left nine o'clock now
is it coming this way
yeah balls are coming up but enemies are
no it turned around oh oh oh didn't
didn't want to do that okay apparently
those spawn enemies but it's just
nothing but balls and enemies don't go
too far down let me look at this for a
while
yeah head back right a little bit Oh
okey [ __ ] cookie [ __ ] [ __ ] we're about
to be boarded I think Oh unless I miss a
bunch going for repairs going for
repairs oh god there's a lot of hits I
was so gross oh yeah if that happens
again just like go backwards up so we
can get some space it was like I went
for repairs but the neck I got one in my
room and the next one was all the way up
the top of the ladder I just couldn't
get there in time that escalated yeah
which we all do it was it was too
peaceful
looks like our gold stash may have been
reset yeah the correct amount of gold
195,000 oh I have eight thousand seven
hundred fourteen I still have I'm not
gonna use it I'm not gonna use come on
come on man hey I'm not gonna use it
okay there's gonna be two one I'm gonna
use the flintlock this time I'm gonna do
an experiment for this first level just
because it's not too threatening I'm
gonna do three engine one gun no shields
all right I'm gonna launch this out of
the water
yeah rampant
oh yeah oh yeah and oh yeah cool all
right to the down I left like 20 percent
of the boat was out of the water 20
percent that's a bath cave left so go
right all right right unless you want to
fight the boss they do have good loot
for loot
I feel like that's we we have a gun to
start my so we can we can do the
strategy just don't get we don't make
super engines I would literally stand
right up by the door you're gonna pop
out firing on this [ __ ] you be
on the right side I believe that kind of
boss ya know like a boss case we're in a
bubble oh all right all right I'll get
on the wait wait go right side okay all
right Wade you've all a left side I'll
try and keep that girl from a few guys
oh he has a laser gun be careful I see
that switchy
good good good rotation cuz I'm good at
dodging the grabs why is it we got rid
of its gravity or oh shoot I know why
okay I'll repair you guys go out there
keep fighting I'll keep fighting wait I
really need health all right like really
need health okay we're going alright all
baited his arm so that's good alright we
can shoot his arms off so focus his
right side and try and get rid of its
blaster arm all right then we'll in just
a second yeah he has a blaster arm
careful okay I gotta sweep it out this
guy [ __ ] hates mark yeah that's okay
though hang on I'm gonna try and get
aggro on the blaster and then do this
oh yeah there's a chain yeah go heal
we're good oh wow hey you can't hit me
here oh you could physically block his
arm oh [ __ ] hey [ __ ] Oh God the
stomping hurts Oh God
stomping hurts I'm here I'll heal you
yeah coming wait I need heals help I got
him I got him I got him I got him oh
yeah oh yeah come on nice nice nice
can I get some wax wait there's a water
pump up here back Stewie oh there's no
there's a wedding ring up here what is
that
maybe treasure oh no it's just a ring
for a long bomb I have known you for so
long now I feel like we're so close on
these seas will you be mine take the
ticket oh wait you asked me to marry you
wait did I I said yes hi I'm 20 health
now Oh what the [ __ ] that's a real thing
yeah you had it propped up mark has
asked you to marry him that I should I
do
we share our health pool it says Chad
marry me yes I guess it doesn't work
both ways but already met my wife I
can't meet her again wait just for good
measure yeah you try and marry you try
and marry one of us something whack me
whack me with it I do
whoa that one had music mark what's your
health I'm at 20 did you get it oh yeah
wait what's your health 20 oh but wait
does that mean if we all share health is
that what chat says that mean we all
collectively only have 20 could buy Dell
points to 20 combined elephants it's
fine no no it'll be fine don't worry
about it it's good I think it's boat
o'clock I think it's gonna be good I
think we're fine we're happy happy Daffy
oh yeah I think so
okay so somewhere in the ship I get Oh
chat says it's not supposed to do that
though we just broke the game maybe all
right cool I'm down for cheats all right
ready here we go how's that shotgun
let's go [ __ ] kill these sharks I
feel like you really need to and really
need to get the full uses guide me mark
you go straight down left get out of our
way seaweed I killed that plant so done
right bubble and shark oh not for long
shark down below I feel crap
maybe shark above big [ __ ] whatever
that is Oh shark box turtle border hang
on oh wait what oh God oh it's really
good
we got an enemy on board and it is very
it is very angry and hurts my last two
health wait so you did stop going down
don't find this stuff I hope he's very
damaging I can't get this ball
[ __ ] oh my god I think I lose double
lumen squid we have a squid wait a squid
double health for every time I get hit
gosh mark there's a hole down here in
the very bottom right the guy down here
is dead okay cool that's the heart you
gotta you gotta you guys by the guns you
got I need a lot P MP maybe sure yes I
need a double yes okay we just need to
heal up and make sure nobody's drowning
I'm drowning I'm healing because wait
ceiling
thanks wood oh I'm healing because
Wade's healing oh it's broken as [ __ ]
right now oh no wait
whack me and see because I think our
utiful humph right no mark no I'm not
with to health wait whack me wait do we
make it so mark there we go alright keep
going keep going keep going keep going
keep going all right okay we're good
alright that's good a little worried
we're good we're good so quit seven five
five four o'clock squid squid squid
switzer squid I have a feeling that
squids gonna be our next boss no okay
is that a cave down straight below yes
it is yeah yeah hermit no no just
regular regular cave yeah Oh get in
there yeah another squid I hate those
things okay
fun fun fun fine I like being married to
you guys I like that we're always the
best marriage we've ever had to each
other I think it'll be good yeah then
when you when you whack like it'll heal
everybody even if you get damaged so
it'll just feel that's true you can heal
yourself now which is like one of the
biggest flaws with being the healer
what's that chess I'm sort of special
ammunition yeah what what we got
oh it's just torpedo ammunition okay I
looked up there's nothing else there
alright and I'm not just saying that
like I usually do theirs trust me there
is nothing up there I actually mean
there's nothing up there that yeah so
what so what we could do with the
healing is
I could be the fighter Marc could be my
healing surrogate and Way could just
heal mark which would keep both of you
healed permanently so we just have an
invincible flavor that makes perfect
sense I love everything about there's a
civilization which is beautiful let's go
we could buy plates whoa is that armor
Oh armor yeah yeah yeah yeah we should
all three of us have to go in here you
go first or whoever goes first I empty
I'm finishing it up we're basically
invincible nothing can go wrong
invincible times we've died trying to
accomplish that exact thing I want to
say I've never accidentally shot or
attacked anybody it is very true I've
never done it yeah when you do you're
bad British accent you definitely know
you're telling the truth - British
accent no this works give me give me
lots of guns all right let me know when
to turn off engines wait you call that
and now okay shields going up oh my god
she's gonna be dead so fast oh my god
Mike
we might be boarded here in a second
work yeah we're about to get grabbed all
right ready and it's just women slowly
around all right it swam into the guns
we're good well good job guys
[ __ ] out of here remember how hard that
was the first time yeah yeah we kind of
did it the wrong way like they used to
board us they don't even try now yeah
well I think
community lead it gave me the D ah max L
whoa one more oh I got one more health
now I have 22 health I only have 21
health I've got 22 infected depths here
we go so let's be ready to EMP if we run
into like a room full of it amazing yeah
yeah I need a double confirmation on
that one I will not do it just because
one guy does it so everyone panics
cheese yeah we need both keys for the
EMP okay anyways clear we got big balls
to the right you're gonna go right as
well okay dodgeball now so don't go yet
don't go farther until we clear this out
yeah there's a ball right just shoot to
the right
it's up I don't know yeah just keep
blasting in that hole there's gonna be
an enemy coming around the corner there
I see it and there's one more around
that lip below us yeah definitely stay
to the right
it's coming up 7:30 8 o'clock both
enemies coming up on our left ones at
10:00 they're turning away question mark
yeah they turned to one down they're off
my radar so we should be clear unless
they suddenly sneak up behind us which
would be real bad I can't see there's a
boss cave to the right but also enemies
below the sucky regular cave do left
what do you guys want I don't care
whichever uh we need money so maybe
regular cave okay
regular cave there's an enemy just below
the sucky so just shoot randomly and
then there's one floaty ball but I think
we can dodge it Bob do you want more gun
no I'm alright okay alright now just go
in the cave we did because what I do is
like I could take away shield because
they wouldn't get close to us if we had
more guns so but maybe it's not worth
the trade-off nah listen boys it's nail
think gross thing very gross it's dead
wait a minute I'm not letting you go up
here alone why not
oh wow that's a lot of you guys wow
thanks for heals to protect you
yeah thank you
gross gross gross gross against
everything appear yeah okay there was a
there was this thing to the right I
think I'm just checking the we can go to
the right here over strobe it's rainin
crawlies that was on the ceiling it
sprained and disgusting and we got a
backpack that oh not that right big
chest no none of us have it right now
you want it weighed probably weighed
yeah yeah yeah why do they have faces
that's what really concerned me is these
things have faces I think that's
probably that is it that's all she wrote
I feel super comfortable guys I think
everything's coming up millhouse yeah
let me know when we were all basically
healed that whole time yeah that works
out marriage is a beautiful thing that
works really three-way marriage yeah
he's going six six 30s around 6:00 5:30
he's got dancing around there
he's far below up let's go through just
yeah yeah grab he's coming in three
enemies whoa they came out of nowhere
go left go left go away from the gravity
okay I couldn't switch that I bought I
didn't have control yet going for my
room as a whole yeah got it coming for
this we're being attacked by these dudes
let me know if any MP is required
I don't think so just three fish man
that's fast all right more oh my god
more dings more dings so you couldn't
spit turn the bus up even though we were
that can't turn it I just like I
couldn't move fast enough wow sounds
like excuses we look good okay there's a
lot of enemies do on the other side of
this pillow they're coming around the
gap to the right around five o'clock
three o'clock now okay they went away
just keep going down in the left maybe
we can avoid them bubbles 6vs stay left
there's an enemy coming in three o'clock
and one o'clock now three o'clock okay
they're going around the other side of
the pillar but there's one enemy 430
South below us there's four enemies
total all do like three o'clock four
o'clock don't keep going down stop all
stop I'm trying
got all enemies not these hurt a lot Oh
God EMP you know okay EMP hit okay
hitting repairs this is not good okay
are we boarded we're not boarded but we
are on me yeah going for the holes
there's a big one up to top why that
driver should be there and just I'm just
getting him sealed so that I can get him
patched up as soon as I get this one I'm
gonna turn on lights and gun but no
engine just okay well we have barnacles
yeah oh God yeah we're being intubated
my room my room squiddy I'm just gonna
put on shields and lights we go there
are many things okay lots of damage
coming in maybe switch the torpedoes
there's four holes up top okay Wow
torpedos not look [ __ ] oh yeah I forgot
about that you should have double gun
though you should have should have full
gun power oh my god leave us alone leave
us alone leave us alone leave us alone
Oh God [ __ ] got a big hole in my two
big holes in my room coming coming
coming I will get that other hole
there's just two holes out here I'm
gonna get them for combos and drowning a
bit Oh big things things little [ __ ]
things in my room bottles yep I could
hit the Liam play again EMP again yeah
yes no no just holes just holes I think
we're all right are we all right
I'm drowning but other than that where's
the last hole there's a hole Wade hit me
I'm gonna die keep hitting me I need it
so badly what the [ __ ] I guess we needed
another EMP I don't know yeah the EMP
wouldn't have killed all the stuff
inside the boat would it no but it would
have given us time to repair
yeah that's okay that section is just
recognize right now man I just so
understand the disbursement of the
enemies there's like nothing and then
there's too many yeah well they I mean
that one we got hit twice and it was
like 2/3 of our health that's the end of
fun today
all right cool good good work cool
[Music]
you